have you uh look when you have 2 800
doors and you have so much stuff
happening
um
how I mean how do you keep up with the
financials like how do you keep up with
everything do you have an accountant
does your wife help like what is this oh
yeah my wife is you know my right hand I
was gonna say because like one of the
biggest things is like I feel like when
you start making that much money
um people make mistakes man Things fall
through the crack they don't dot their
eyes they don't cross their T's so what
are the things that like you would just
suggest people make sure they have in
line if you once you've kind of start
getting that many streams of income
coming in you definitely want to have a
good real estate accountant right when I
first started I was using uh this
accountant right she was local I used
her for a couple years
and one day she tells me caesar I'm
learning with you
and I'm like what do you mean you're
learning with me
as you're doing real estate I'm learning
with you so but I'm like you're the
professional you're supposed to be
teaching me that tricks of the time so
at that point I know I had to change
accounts right and now I have a a new
accountant uh you know that I save a lot
of money with right because real estate
is one of those uh Financial Vehicles
where you don't pay a lot when it comes
to taxes right there's so many loopholes
in the tax code right that are actually
legal right uh so you definitely need a
good real estate accountant to take
advantage of those loopholes you got to
put a good team together when it comes
to property managers right and
contractors uh contractor part whenever
I find a contractor it's really good I
just keep them year round
look I just hired him to keep them in
the house you'll be like yo you work for
me yeah and then of course you need uh
good property management software like
we use AppFolio at folio is really good